Hank: Good morning, John, I have developed
an unhealthy obsession with the word 'cool'.
Not the concept of 'cool', that's just--I
mean--that's a lot and I'm clearly not an
expert.
I mean the word or words that we use to identify
that mutable mix of simultaneously embodying
and defying culture and defining culture as
well, if nothing else, cool and its neighborhood
of words attempt to define a leading edge
of cultures' aesthetic, an edge that seems
out of everyone's control, precisely because
it's controlled by everyone, and there are
a lot of these words precisely for that reason.
As culture changes, it needs new words to
embody itself, because those old words are
defining an old culture, and as culture changes
faster, we get more and more of them.
Now, it's widely accepted that the word with
the most synonyms in English is drunk.
This was, I think, first proposed by Benjamin
Franklin, and it is difficult to argue with,
but mostly because it's just very hard to
measure slang.
In any case, though, I think that 'cool' could
give 'drunk' a run for its money.
Dope, rad, bad, off the heezy, the bee's knees,
on the ball, peachy keen, slammin', smokin',
sweet, far out, groovy, hip, legit, boss,
wizard, wicked, jokes, choice, gnarly, the
cat's pajamas, crackalackin, nifty, fine,
fab, fly, fresh, phat, and on fleek.
Just to name a few!
Culture defines the words and the words define
the culture.
The very existence of the concept of cool
itself requires a kind of cultural self-awareness.
Culture needs to know that culture exists,
so it can identify and co-opt words to use
to define itself with, but I think that culture
is aware of itself in a kind of limited way.
Like, when I look at myself in the mirror,
I'm seeing myself on the surface level.
I can like, do my hair and check for my pimples,
but not really gettin' very deep.
When I think about myself, though, I'm thinking
about my hopes and my fears and my motivations,
and the effects that I have on the world around
me.
That's what I'm thinking about my actual self,
and that's a whole other thing.
Culture, it feels like, is kinda of often
mindlessly self-aware, like it's looking at
itself in the mirror and being quite impressed
with what it sees there, but not examining
itself in a deeper way.
Culture has a hard time being truly self-aware,
being able to examine itself, its motivations,
its effects, and its hopes and its fears.
It's hard for culture to do that, but one
way that we can do it is to examine the choices
that culture makes, and maybe that'll give
us some deeper insight, and 'cool', that bleeding
edge of the collective self, is a really good
place to look for that insight.
Like in the 60s, with the focus on both space
exploration and drug culture, words for 'cool'
were like, 'far out', and 'out of this world'
or just 'gone'.
Surfer culture was more about enthusiasm than
aloofness, and spawned words like 'mondo'
and 'bodacious' and 'radical'.
These words almost always come to the mainstream
from some kind of subculture, out of rock
and roll or punk or beat poets, but most commonly,
they come out of marginalized cultures.
The first use of 'cool' itself to identify
the concept of coolness was traced back to
the 1880s in African-American English.
Often, these words are co-opted and redefined
by the mainstream in a kind of colonization
of the cool of marginalized cultures that
the mainstream has itself marginalized.
Diversity creates these opportunities for
cultural advancement, but the wave can also
be destructive if we forget that we're the
ones who built it and don't question its effects.
Ultimately, and thank goodness, we get to
decide for ourselves what 'cool' is.
We both create and are created by culture.
So maybe we have an obligation to inspect
that wave and to see if we can understand
its motivations and its effects.
And that is why I have become obsessed with
the word 'cool'.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Please, I want so badly for there to be productive
discussion in the comments.
There was a lot that I couldn't say in this
video, because there's just not enough time,
so I hope a lot of that discussion gets to
happen down in the comments.
Also, I'm going to be performing with Welcome
to Night Vale in Portland and Seattle on October
27th and 28th, and yes, NerdCon: Stories is
still a thing that's going to be happening
October 9th and 10th in Minneapolis.
Post-VidCon, we've been doing a lot of talking
and planning about NerdCon: Stories and I'm
really excited about it.
We've sold most of the tickets, but not all
of them.
Okay.
Goodbye.